[Music]
yo what up reject Nation we have made it
to episode 4 I am so excited I've heard
this is a good one really I don't know I
was just making stuff up been in the
same room with you the past few hours I
haven't heard anything CG take your mask
off why because it's Mass grade ohone
was like you know I wish I could intro
the video so I can make my Mas that's
true every time I come here I just beg
you to intro of the videos and you don't
let me guys guys guys um and gals and
gals don't want to exclude the
gals leave a like on this video that
would be great who's your favorite gal
of all time tele friend to tell friend
subscribe and click that Bell to get
notify want a reaction for five is up
here on this very Channel you haven't
seen our other reactions this one
they're of course here I hope you like
the reviews because that's where most of
our thoughts go into it yeah that makes
sense yes yes yes yes Greg let's
go
wo uh someone edited this video thank
you full length Reaction watch along
where you see with your own copy of hasb
been Hotel available for super sex
Rejects at our patreon page cover
several things super there H watch s all
right Roxy Do It Rocky name things that
rhyme with four back and forth go four
Thor score
more
poor core door lore
sure roar I did that one already you
said Roar yeah I said
Roar that doesn't
count whoa what is going on finally
awake angel dust yeah and what's it to
you maybe this is a that she filmed or
he filmed maybe yeah fine I guess I'll
just have to St the information out of
here yeah yeah yeah do your worst daddy
daddy this performance want me a sex SE
sexy one it's uh very honest that is a
word for it authentic you know not a
very convincing interrogation scene oh
are we going to get to know him this
episode you really going to sit there
and act like these scripts ain't hot
garbage this is classy
art
I know everything about you and these
mother at this point that one is an
insecure buffoon whose lonely ass
watches you idiot sleep o read them for
f princess is a bleeding heart who wants
to solve everybody else's problem except
her own oh my God he's the most film The
War of them all this one judges everyone
and everything because she hates herself
this a great deconstruction and Nifty
yeah you don't even want to know what
her do I kind of do I really do and you
don't get me started I see right through
you and all this [__] L out I'll
fake you all
wow I had no idea guess that's why I'm
an actor
dumbass yeah that's me no no I just I no
I no looks like B needs me for an uh
emergency shoot mhm sure you know what I
don't give a [__] what some drunk ass
bartender thinks of me I think you do
I'm sure you'll manage without me there
isn't much time left for the hotel to
prove itself what unique characters what
am I doing right wrong well I mean
you're the princess of hell so you don't
really use the power that comes with
that which I love about
you I don't know command a little more
Authority but that's so mean respect my
authority that's so
mean I could be so aggressively kind to
Angel's boss she's so Amy po to me man
convince him to let Angel spend more
time in the hotel oh no she's going to
get Angel fired oh Oh Daddy
I do you really expect me to memorize
this whole script just improv it do you
think anyone watches for the dialogue a
what an insult I guess I'll have to do
all of
you who this is adult
animation uh my name's Rocky no one
gives you [__] oh so this is where the
magic what in the ever loving are you
doing I'm here to get you some time off
for the hotel now where's your boss oh
you are going nowhere in the angel what
is the hold up uhoh I'm coming not off
camera you're not abusive ass
relationship what can I do for such
a you don't want to roll do you because
I could make you a star make us both
richer than well you're pap no richer
than the devil well let's take this [__]
from the top action I sure hope you
don't hurt me with those don't move you
spicy little uh
sleeve F sleep oh my God I'm sorry I was
just telling him about the hman hotel
not at all princess it doesn't bother me
one no no going to get hurt if you want
help with the script Maybe I can pitch
some scenarios that are more oh
no okay okay oh what have you
done you're ruining a perfectly good
film whoa that was pretty cool yeah I I
can clean this up I I can don't you
worry your pretty blonde head about it
we have people for that can I see you in
your dressing room for a moment oh no is
he going to get beat I was thinking
about that F I didn't
know damn it you really think you can
have Lucifer's little [__] fight your
battles for you this is horrifying you
know she can't do
anything I own you or have you forgotten
that oh I see I see when I say you are
20 guys before lunch you say yes
Valentino this is disturbing you better
get
that out of my St Studio look Val this
is absolutely horrifying wow now you're
going to go get rid of her and then
you're filming all night get me I mean
we are in hell I know no it's actually
feeling like evil yeah and I have been
waiting for it to like feel like truly
evil people get your asses back on set
and we are taking this from the top what
makes you think you can treat him like
oh just stop Angel what are you talking
Charlie leave oh no you made think worse
I just wanted to help you you actually
want to help me get out of here a no I
didn't mean too I'm the dyamic seeing
like an American Horror Story season or
some [__] good boy and like a Zach Kinto
character a song let's go I'm not a
bubble of to cashing another lover
underneath those flashing light another
one of
Ruth man this is so so
unpleasant
po this a great song though this seems
like like a straight up PO up
song like a Jonas brother's One
Direction this is like a story of like
addiction and debauchery I got so good
at being
untrue I got so good at telling you what
you want to hear it's the most oppressed
character well we knew that uh angel
dust was on drugs we understand
[Music]
why it's pretty bold the way they're
doing
[Music]
this damn this is bold [__] man story is
going to end with Mead from your poison
poison I appreciate the commitment to
the harrowing side of it yeah it's a
little hard to watch so yeah no it's it
especially cuz it's animated
too why do you think he signed the
contract probably wanted fame or some
[__] I need a drink you look like [__]
not possible just a long Sho nothing new
it's kind of interesting see for a guy
character too you know yeah normally I
feel like this would be a more female Dr
roll if you got a problem you're not
going to find the solution at the bottom
of a bottle I should know I've been
looking there a long time then where
should I look in your bedroom maybe
maybe we can go look together this is a
very unique show man God damn you can
cut the ACT already it's never going to
work on me so all you're doing is making
an ass out of yourself with this fake
[__] to me face one more time
mother you would be lucky to get a
chance to me you know how many people
would kill to have angel dust come on De
M have fun being a lonely piece of [__]
whoa he looked really upset it's just
Angel you'll be fine I'm not so sure I
really messed up at the studio today and
he got it wasn't good okay they have
masterfully handled transitioning tones
that look he'll come back when he's
ready I just don't want anything to
happen to him until then now if you'll
excuse me I'm going to go write 100
apology letters and a lesson plan for
tomorrow about
Foundry all the fainting Embrace that
you know Angel does of the lifestyle he
lives is just all an escape he's got no
choice too yeah so I said you couldn't
afford me in a million after lives you
got hey baby be a doll and bring me
another one coping mechanisms this is
sad Greg I think it's really it's bold
that the show would do this on their
fourth episode I know I know it's more
like a season 2 kind of [__] you get you
know nice
try let's go classic barf fight that put
something in your drink you don't think
I can tell if someone spikes my drink I
do this all the time oh Jesus you think
I asked for it I don't ask for any of
this [__] I didn't ask to be this way
wow I can handle myself really so much
because I just saw someone
self-destructive exactly it seems like
you might need a bartender to talk to
Classic you think after how you treated
me I'm going to open up to you maybe I'd
treat you better if you were
real let me tell you nobody in that
hotel cares who you are how famous haha
so you might as well just cut the a they
care who you want or anything it's not
an act it's who I need to be and this
this is my escape and survival mechanism
where I can forget about it all how much
I hate everything this a so film Noir
yeah but with colors if I can ruin
myself enough in the process if I end up
broken I won't be his favorite toy
anymore oh that is heartbreaking I like
hate this Greg I was an Overlord once
you know
really it was nice to have that power
but when you're dealing in Soul while
ooh also being a gambler the mistakes
are pretty high and losing a few hands
can be more than a little dangerous
right you turn to anything to keep you
AF float even making deals yourself so I
know what it's liked oh yeah cuz we know
regret the choices made and no one you
can't take it back what a fascinating
show so things look bad and your backs
against the W songs are such a reward
every time there's catharus to them
you're feeling filthy as a dive bar
bathroom
stall oh my God can't face the world
sober and
dop you think your life is wrecked well
let me just say you're
correct except the reality you're a
loser baby
a up little whiny [__] you're a loser
just like me my God affirm the realities
I needed this so bad cuz I was so sad
just now
Yom but you got company yeah there was a
time I thought that no one could relate
this person's voice is Bomb it's Keith
David Oh Yeah
Yeahs
down straight Amen to that I sold my
soul to a psychopathic freak and you you
think that makes you
unique what a layer
light baby will Los it's
okay
honey damn got anti for gambling got
anti what a great animation I got no
hoes left to deflow i s my soul to save
my power I'm
trapped wow this being the two of their
episode is cool it's an ensemble show
right now it's time to Lose Yourself
this is a very moving episode play your
card be who you are a loser just like
there he is
singing oh I love that song [__] stay
down I'll deal with this time to be
badass
whoa cool oh my God he's the coolest
character in the whole
showat sucker
teamwork awesome I can handle myself
baby wow well that was something I
didn't expect to see like very Guardians
of the Galaxy right now it's exactly
what I'm sing
yeah he he had like like three bills a
and baggie said to send husk and this is
the guy you got to take orders from I
know what a joke right I'm
so ever Charlie it's fine I get it
thanks for caring about me
[Music]
a I think this is yours okay Missy yeah
said for forgive
[Music]
[Laughter]
me [__] like Maggie you read my mind we
finally came to a easy one to commit to
memory that was
awesome when we saw that it said 18 plus
and all the other episodes 16 plus I was
like how could it get raunchier really
like how could how could animation and
then yeah this just made it like it's
dealing with really really effed up
traumatic like horrible things that was
wild that they were able to pull that
off I I don't even know how they did
that I feel like usually with a with
shows that are special that are that
start off as so comedically heavy you
don't get your your real serious thing
and till like a special episode like a
later season you know and totally the
way they have managed
to I don't know how to expl it's been
like this like a like a little wave that
has gone into elements that get more
serious over time because it it doesn't
feel like it's out of this realm for the
show to go there cuz that seed has
always been there like from the very
from the pilot you know not not episode
one but the pilot uh this whole idea
we're talking about reform and the way
the Reformation is happening is by
uncovering who people really are
underneath the surface right because at
with someone like Charlie she has always
seen that at the end of the day they are
souls and there are people under before
there was the darkness there was light
and that Darkness has clouded that light
and who that light is is who these
people really are and she wants to like
unpack that so all this like cliche
trusting EX aren't going to be the trick
so it it is through form via of
connection it is through form of just
being honest with yourself and dealing
with the current reality that's why I
love that loser song because it it is
just them affirming the truth and
accepting that and being okay with that
and instead of trying to be like no
you're not don't do that don't think
this it is just about being like where
you are right now and that's okay yeah
radical acceptance and practicing that
it's like if you've made the choices
you've made and you have to live
somewhere you are living right now
what's the point in further judging that
and further punishing yourself when what
the choices you've made are already
punishing you enough yeah you know and I
think that that it it's like two
different sides of the same coin with
the two of them as we're seeing the
gambling versus the sex working and like
it um selling your soul to somebody and
not having power over your your body
your choices whatever it is just can't
believe that this show that started the
way it did was able to tonally shift
so so uh seamlessly because they painted
such we've talked about in previous
episodes this world building we're just
in different Pockets right like it's not
like this felt like a different world
this just felt like a little different
corner of Hell MH and we've seen other
corners of hell and my last the last
episode we watched remember my questions
are like what's going on with Lilith
what's going on with the um devil uh
radio man what's going whatever not one
of my questions was like what's up with
angel dust and the bartender yeah and so
I didn't think that's what I gave a crap
about as much and then they were like oh
here's why you should care and I'm like
oh you're right I do care now thank you
for telling me why I should care you
know it's not it's not where our minds
were going going into episode 4 and then
they were just like no this is what we
want to do with episode 4 it kind of
reminds me this is such a weird one but
did you see The Last of Us you did CU
you have that sick shirt from it so I
know that you watch the show yeah um the
episode where we go to Nick offerman's
character yeah and I didn't play the
video game obviously but it's like it's
just such a standalone episode moment
that breaks off so early on in the show
that I'm kind of like whoa that was
ballsy and risky that that's what you
guys want to do and this kind of for
different reasons felt like that where
this they're like they're making this
choice and they probably know this means
they could lose some of their audience
and they could gain the respect of the
people who stay even more because what a
bold decision this was that was wild
that was a wild TV episode yeah because
this gets to uncomfortable terrain this
gets to Ser this is serious business
right here we're talking about like all
kinds of levels of abuse of power and
ways that are very degrading and dehum
and dehumanizing and
also play on very realistic thing that's
the thing is like they they they as much
as they're like oh it's cool animation
and they they do some things with uh
making them hellish characters still
feels like very real cuz at its
emotional core the characters the way
they're uh I don't mean this in just in
an animation sense just the uh
figuratively speaking the illust the way
they're Illustrated and the way the
Dynamics are Illustrated it's it's scary
it's intense because it feels like real
you know and uh and I I I respect it so
much because there's been all the
episodes have been like we've been
saying I feel like there's like
something deeper here but I don't know
if we're just going deeper or if we're
just supposed to accept that are we
thinking more into it than the show and
then you get to this you're like no this
show has 100% been deeper this entire
time and it I love that it respects the
audience enough to go far past just
being you know fun musical comedy and go
right to and do something like this to
make it more human like take a character
who just was kind of this one note joke
and really make them more human over
time all of them were like all these
characters we've gotten to know everyone
at this hasman hotel so much better now
yeah and and with all different genres
splic through in to keep an engaging
focus and then you get a song like that
which is like a a real it has that like
80s pop song FLIR to it like a movie
moment but if it feels
it was serious it it was moving you're
like watching The Vision like man this
is disturbing yeah I love your point
going back though about how we kept
being like Oh there's so many layers
here but then you're like is that are
those accidental layers or those layers
just like me extrapolating from this
like but then they show us this and you
know they've planted every single one of
those seeds they know exactly what
they're doing which I think is just yeah
it's it's
unbelievable uh yeah this show has my
attention
well there's no show like it no no this
show has my attention because as
somebody I know I started this in the
pilot saying this I watched 115 Plus
shows every single year so to get to
really have my attention and be able to
be like I I've never seen anything like
this and I've never seen anything like
this yeah well it's like first it's like
on the surface it it feels like
nostalgic in the way it's just drawn but
the way the way the world gets more
fleshed out not bad I was just drawn
that
way name movie that's a she's a she's a
God I know it a red
dress it's half animation half
not frame Roger R
yeah he gave it away there I was like
well it's either Space Jam or who frame
Roger R so I'm that bad I was just drawn
that
way anyway oh Betty what's peep poop
boop beep B peep oh my God her first of
all that girl's name is Betty Boop and
the other person's name you're trying to
say is Little B peep who's the girl who
said it rabbit that was Jessica Rabbit
who said it I don't know I think so I
don't recall but uh yeah uh Beautiful
episode and great good musical oh and
then the last thing like uh the thing
tooo you go first no you go first no
it's okay I already forgot mine no cuz I
[__] it up no no no you just go
uh I don't remember now here a
while oh I remember oh I remember I
remember I was worried at first in this
episode because I thought they were I
didn't know if I was going to enjoy
their stance on sex workers like I
thought they were being judgmental the
show it for the first um part of this
episode I didn't know where they were
going with like the fact that they were
um that like he was doing this and it
seemed like they the show was looking
down upon it but really what they were
doing was putting us in the perspective
of um the the princess and bringing us
into like oh savior mode and that was
not where we needed to be this is just
like the reality of this guy's
situation yeah I mean it's like I I
think obviously there is that stereotype
when it comes to sex workers of yeah
they're all just damaged people you know
it's not true right so that's what I was
thinking that they were showing but
that's not what was happening which I
was glad about no and it exp it actually
exposes a commentary on a different side
of real world stuff you know that is
very tragic and and harming and harmful
and uh and and it actually works within
genre
of because this is such a throwback vibe
to like you know the 30s to 50s of those
old kind of like Hollywood starlets who
would be like abused and used and and um
tossed around and stuff so I I think
like it still works within the framew
framework of the genre that it riffs the
the time period that it really riffs on
uh so yeah I thought that was excellent
man I I was moved to Tears by the end
that was really touching it was really
good really really good I'm stoked for
however many episodes we have left we
got toast just two two yeah so Roxy and
I we watched five today pilot one two
three four five and then we got just two
to do when they are and they drop at the
same time yeah so did they release these
two at a time we don't
know I have no idea
Hollywood weird release schedule anyway
guys what do you think about this
episode is it one of your f AV where you
move to leave your thoughts down below
catch you for episode five and six later
dudes Chase
Gardner Chase happy New Year Chase
Garder man boy if I know Chase and
believe me we know each other really
well no one knows Chase like you I know
exactly what your New Year's resolution
is going to be for the year
2024 yes all right you are going to
collect as many gnomes as possible yes
you need a hobby become a gnome
collector you need a niche because the
next person that ticks you off oh all
right let's say and if I know Chase he's
very easily perturbed
by
the slightest [__] that happens in
public all right let's say uh you're you
know waiting in line at your your
nearest
7-Eleven and the person's just taking
[__] forever to check out you're just
like come on man I've been here for a
while seriously who brings change
anymore yeah why is he counting and
giving exact change how big is your coin
jar at 711 swipe your credit card you
have AB wallet I I could see this is
building up in you oh and there it goes
now you've made a mortal enemy now you
got to follow this person to their house
this person who owns a house who
apparently pays in change I know wild
character right they just a pen very
very precise finances so they so then
you fall in her home and then what do
you do with all your known they wake up
in the middle of the night after you
dingdong ditch them when they wake up to
a display of gnome every imaginable
gnome out in their front yard horrified
staring up at
them it's the
ultimate ultimate Challenge just to get
back yeah and if that doesn't work how
scary would that be that would be
horrifying to come out and just see like
a bunch of inexplicable gnomes yeah I
thought about this for days yes it would
be it would be hor it would be worse
than that Goosebump
there's like a bunch of them and they're
alive but I mean like I don't know even
if they weren't alive just like the
thought and I don't know it's like you
wouldn't want to turn your back plus if
it doesn't work you could just grab one
and Club them over the head with it that
always works this chair makes me a very
bendy person ooh is your yoga chair it's
your flexa throne I have been very I
have been stretching again that's good
it's good for you stretchy 2024 I need
to get the Spitz back John you do that
could be your thing
again you can shoot it in portrait and
put it on Tik Tok and be like splits
reactions I just my Instagram could just
be like I'm going to do the splits
here oh my God I'm going go to the store
and do the splits I'm G to go to here
the
splits such a funny Instagram that would
be really great I'm going to church I'm
going do the
splits and the thing is the more you
grow that you know some [__] like that
would just take off for no reason it
would and thing is you would be able
eventually as it picks up to write off
trip after vac I'm going to do splits
the Eiffel Tower I'm going to do my
splits in the leading Tower Pisa I'm
going to do my splits in the catacombs
below
Paris I'll do my splits in an ancient
Monastery I'm doing my splits at the
Make A Wish Foundation today with some
sick kids splits guy
yeah cuz that's what the algorithm
favors it's just yeah pick a pick a lane
I think you just got to do to a public
setting and just don't announce it and
just like I'm just going to do like
don't make a deal just that random dude
flash of the split just you it's just
one guy if I could just get to a point
where I could like how when I was really
young where I could just fall into it at
a moment's notice just like fall I used
to be able to jump tuck my knees and
then fall into the split I was like so
obsessed with doing the splits so if I
can get to that point again where I'm
just out in public and
I and then every like get the reaction
from
like bam right off and then every like
seventh or eighth one you do a front
split oh just to mix it up good the
front I'm trying really trying to get it
okay that's as I've gotten older the
part of my body that's gotten the more
stiff I have clicking shoulders oh I've
have clicking
shoulders and I have really stiff hips
so I've been stret Str doing a lot of
random hip stretches anyway chase this
is because of you steal this idea now
have a new Instagram page to
work that a hilarious Instagram you just
got to get the right name got to do the
splits where two splits how two split
it's got to be something so simple it's
stupid like splits Greg or something
Greg
splitz G
Spitz spit spitzy
[Laughter]
COA oh yeah funny do the splits
Chase and then I can find some other
scammers do the exact same thing we
should collap we should do it we got to
meet him somewhere to do the splits and
then yeah yeah find somebody who does
like splits and then you guys can team
up and then find someone who do
cartwheels to like do a cartwheel behind
you you do those like VR things that
people do they C
around and and then you could do you
there's so many collab opportunities and
they would all be like 3C videos but you
you could like grow like a whole ass
circus surrounding this a funny assd
scrip dud that would be really
funny and it's the perfect it's easy to
do sort of it's it's easy enough to do
it's easy to capture it's quick it's not
messy it doesn't get the way of anything
everyone would be like this guy doesn't
do any work all he does is do the splits
be like I'll have you know I have to
maintain I work very hard to get to the
point of doing this
yeah and it's something I've been
maintaining from a young I have to work
really hard to make sure I can still do
the splits For You For Your
Entertainment just so I could walk into
Denny's and do the and I get a free
moons over my
hammy dude the perks man the perks
thanks buddy love
[Music]
you